the attacks come with terrifying
regularity here in the world's largest
mangrove swamp in the Bay of Bengal
villagers trudged through a murky river
to net shrimp larvae locals speak of a
monster that attacks underwater without
warning it happened to sumitra mystery
it was an ordinary day I woke up and
then I went for fishing in the river I
was pulling my net in the water for
three hours when the animal bit me it
was like a sharp razor cut
I pushed the animal and it immediately
took off my hand I swam to the shore and
saw the blood running from my hand
many here bear the scars of these
frightening encounters National
Geographic biologist rocky strong an
adventurer Fabien Cousteau have come to
investigate rocky believes the culprit
might be a bull shark
they set the bait
why this spot versus any other this is a
place where two major rivers converge
and even more importantly all the locals
say this is a good spot for sharks
something is biting but the researchers
can't make a catch
well no no really even good-good bytes I
have to say it's the longest time I've
spent fishing without any results at all
later they're led to a market were two
small sharks are for sale so in here
goodness gracious
ah this is this is a brand new pup by
the look of the umbilical marks these
pups were newborns to determine the
species the researchers count T five six
seven eight nine and ten that's our fish
it's conclusive these are bull sharks as
rocky suspected this sometimes
aggressive species has been documented
in rivers throughout the world
Rocky's theory is that bull sharks
develop the ability to live temporarily
in freshwater so that females can give
birth where their young are safest from
other sharks but maybe it's after giving
birth that the females had further up
river in search of food
sometimes encountering people why Upper
River versus say further down the coast
or deeper into the ocean because they
can because they can leave all their
competitors behind and be king of the
hill up inside a an environment that
they're very good at dealing with and
other sharks just aren't
both shark and human are seeking food in
these waters to help them survive and
that competition can sometimes lead to
dangerous clashes